[Musique]
je suis richard comment tu t'appelles
maire
abandonner pour miss lady hawk elle-même
pourquoi t'appellent-ils une lady hawk
j'ai tiré dans un match de basket
il y a 25 ans tu penses que tu es un héros
j'adore ça regarde  que ça a dû être
des coups de feu la plupart des endroits
pas ici
ouais
que faites-vous maire je suis un détective un
détective
vous n'avez pas de corps cachés sous
votre porche
n'est-ce pas encore pas
le département de police d'Easttown a reçu
un appel signalant  un cadavre dans le
ruisseau de la liberté attrape
ce fils de [ __ ] tu as fait ça
parce que si tu ne le fais pas je le tuerai moi
-même parle moi de ton père il était mon meilleur
ami il est décédé quand j'avais 13 ans il
était détective
à  au moins tu as encore ta mère oh
on ne se
supporte pas  ce que tu as traversé
et je sais que tu vaux la peine d'être sauvé
[Musique]
le sol s'effondre sous
toi m  om nous ne savons pas ce qui va
se passer d'accord
retournez au fichier creusez profondément réengagez
-vous